garda on avait c'est un petit peu la
lumière on bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
il le fait bien mais avec ses yeux
dirait charles trenet oui il était
vachement bien regarder parfait bien
alors c'est une interview sans la bouche
et je ne peux pas parler voilà dont vous
ne parlez pas c'est pas de blabla du
tout là et vous allez répondre avec des
gestes dont je vous posais des questions
et vous allez répondre avec des avec des
gestes prévention parce que moi j'ai une
grande bavarde d'accord alors vous avez
justement c'est ce que vous êtes une
bavarde donc le matin les premiers
exemples comme ça le matin vous vous
réveillez vous regarder dans la glace
tout va bien
j'adore c'est à dire les buts sont la
viande ou pas à vous pouvez dire tout ce
que vous voulez vous mais ça repose une
interview sans la bouche voyait alors le
matin vous vous réveillez tout va mal
vous êtes dans la rue vous conduisez
vous êtes dans l'art avec une copine
dans une voiture et un camion poubelle
qui vous bloquent la rue et vous êtes
prêt si vous avez un rendez vous vous
ouvrez la fenêtre
elle a parlé en cas brawn et
elle l'a fait ou cela on essaye quoi
vous amenez votre votre fille à l'école
et vous partez de l'école vous êtes un
peu triste de la laisser là un peu
triste de vous voir partir et elle et
vous la voyez à travers la ville voulu
vous la regardez à travers la vie de
vous lui faites quoi
d'accord vous vous êtes à un feu rouge
dans la voiture votre copine voyait un
super mec au feu rouge
par l'on voulait bien coiffé mois un
chèque que je tapais
votre numéro
vous allez bouffer dans un restaurant la
dernière fois qu'on a dîné ensemble
c'est un super bon je vais vous le dire
vraiment
ouais je fais le calme bon mais là la
bouffe et ce soir là la bouffe est
infect vite quoi aux patrons
way et il a une panne sexuelle vous lui
dites quoi
avant
ce que vous faites
et si ça marche pas
ah ouais vous essayerez à vous essayez
rien d'autre
oui bon
enfin j'ai plein de stratagème lui
et bien c'est très bien j'ai applaudi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon interview sans la bouche vous
connaissez max interview sans tabou y
connaissez
une interview peuvent pas répondre en
parlant donc ils vont être obligés de
mimer leurs réponses vous préférez
hitler ou staline
il ya un site internet qui s'est créée
pour demander votre retour sur comédie
vous personnellement vous préfériez
l'époque vous étiez sur comédie ou npa
avec nagui
npa avec nagui
a plutôt comédie
[Rires]
nagui vous trouvez comment dans un pea
est-ce que ça le fait comme il dit lui
trop d'accord est-ce que vous rêvez je
fais comment la tva est ce que vous
rêvez d'avoir une émission à vous
combien de temps vous pensé que j'allais
être encore ensemble les robins des bois
francs comme un damné
si jean-paul si vous deviez signifier
votre attirance pour votre camarade
marina vous le feriez comment
et vous
est
ce que vous trouvez que les robins des
bois sont drôles
[Musique]
et vous
si je m'en vais faire un gag vous feriez
quoi
s'acheter
dans bouge on fait quoi
mais vous n'êtes
pas bougé pendant le jingle que
maintenant il avait pu à bouger pendu ce
soir exceptionnellement ont peu bougé
pendant le jingle super conditionné
thierry tu sais voilà alors donc c'est
une interview sans la bouche donc je
vous posais des questions et vous allez
me répondre sans parler c'est une
interview sans la bouche de quelle
humeur et vous le matin quand vous vous
réveillez
oui d'accord
d'accord moi j'aimerais pas trois buts
avec l'uruguay
quelle est la première chose que vous
faites en vous levant
quelle est votre position préférée pour
prendre votre petit déjeuner
jeudi sur la boucherie
imaginons c'est un peu comme dans votre
livre un couple de 1 coupe de notre
temps là votre fille vous annonce
qu'elle est enceinte vous réagissez
comme en
est à pire si c'est votre fils qui vous
annonce qu'il est en simple réajustement
j'aimerais pas trop aidé son fils
étudiant sur un
imaginaire c'est comme dans le film les
insaisissables de questions géants
initiés débarque chez vous faites quoi
vous sortez dans la rue le matin il ya
un clochard qui vous demandent l'aumône
voulu donner une petite pièce et il vous
dit que c'est pas assez vous réagissez
comment
[Rires]
vous arrivez sur le tournage de la
vérité de tout le monde c'est tout le
monde se marre tout sens en vous voyant
et vous savez pas pourquoi
d'accord pensez à quoi donc je vais pas
alors au déjeuner il ya une figurante
qui vous drague
vous êtes du genre à couper court tout
de suite ouais
mais cette phase on avait dit qu'on n'en
parlait pas en même temps je suis un peu
voilà donc après une journée de tournage
vous rentrez chez vous et le clochard
vous insulte à nouveau s'ils voulaient
pas donner c'est une atteinte à votre
femme vous annonce qu'elle est enceinte
de l'huissier et vous vous péter les
plombs c'est comment quand vous péter
les plombs et de montrer tout à l'heure
vous avez gagné un cadeau la calotte
et voilà on rallume merci donc je vais
les autres petits cadeaux
merci qui
et
y en a certains balladur gonfle patins
dégonfle pas c'est bon c'est bon j'ai
senti l'énergie atomique alors ouais bah
écoute pendant toute l'émission je me
trompe et le pousse
pas perdre mon temps tu vois c'est moi
j'ai un pana reeve
c'est pour ça que j'ai demandé de l'eau
propre
vas-y tiré fait un gros plan sur mon
pouce pas fait un gros plan sur le pouce
du penher et les gros perdants c'est
bien bas reste comme ça jusqu'à la fin
donc une caméra diverger serge sur la la
c'est bon la version moins en à bouche
pendant six heures
alors dans un dîner un producteur très
connus vous proposant rôle très
important en vous appelant françoise
toujours dans ce dîner
arrive votre pire ennemi
moufter pas
la bouffe est infect dans ce dîner à
chier
alors bon la bouffe est un fake vous
picoler effectivement un moment vous
allez aux toilettes vous vous trompez de
portes et vous tombez sur un couple deux
mecs en train de baiser
est d'accord à la fin du dîner tout le
monde offre un cadeau aux maîtres de
maison parce qu'en fait ce dîner était
organisé pour son anniversaire vous avez
rien à lui offrir
ah bon ça suffit
alors vous rentrez chez vous ou en
voiture les flics vous arrête
ils vous reconnaissez pas
à la lie le reconnaît
en arrivant chez vous il ya une lettre
du laboratoire vous êtes enceinte
tremonti
oui
d'accord
votre fils vous appelle il pourra pas
vous rejoindre cette nuit ça fait deux
fois cette semaine
1 à votre âge
[Musique]
voilà donc
est-ce que kenza du loft et votre soeur
croyez vous que les américains vont
faire un hiroshima en irak
et semaine on vous a un peu parlé fait
gaffe que pensez vous des hommes qui
portent des costumes noirs
que pensez vous de moi
c'est bon on se comprend vachement bien
la
pensée quad moi vous
jamais été jusqu'à égaré dépensé sur toi
non je trouve sympathique puis j'aime
beaucoup de maintenant le cas plus tard
est sur le côté c'est mieux là non je
préfère avant
la faire avant avant tu faisais prof
d'éco libre maintenant tu fais
un métier voyous n'ont
jamais jamais cet ordre dans quelque
chose de bien tracé kenzo il a touché à
la mode il touche à la musique il va
bien de barbouiller un truc à la
coiffure mais bien sûr
kenzo
que pensez vous de vous
que pensez-vous du psg
ouais
bien
il s'est rattrapé que pensez-vous de la
drogue
ah ouais c'était avant à l'époque vous
étiez tous venus du premier balcon du
palais c'était une autre époque oui
d'accord que pensez-vous de la religion
à vous êtes bouddhiste oui oui quand
vous êtes au japon par exemple vous
allez faire des offrandes au temple
un petit peu ouais que pensez vous des
gens qui ont tout pour être heureux
ouais et des gens qui ont rien pour être
heureux
que pensez vous de cette interview kenzo
[Musique]
jean-paul
interviews sont la bouche attention ne
dit rien vous êtes dans une soirée
claude berri vous vous salue en vous
appelant jean pierre rives vous êtes
obligé de sourire parce que c'est claude
berri vous souriez comment
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite un photographe arrive fait
qu'elle t'aide sur la photo jean-paul à
ce moment là une sublime gonzesses entre
ne regarde que vous vous êtes
inaccessible fait kate est inaccessible
mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop mais pas trop
inaccessible inaccessible h une
excessive au patro pas trop
à l'ats
nicole kidman arrive dans cette soirée
où il ya claude berri déjà nicolas
sarkozy est nécessaire phase i et alors
vous voient comme c'est fait aïe alan
vous faites quoi vont
ils le font parce que c'est kidman
excuses il dit qu'est ce qui fait que ce
blaireau
jean-paul vous vous croisez quelqu'un de
visiblement important en fait vous
l'avez pas reconnu c'est le nouveau
comics et alain delon fait quelle tête
jamais vécu
jean paul jean pierre guérin le
producteur de gilles escot vous raconte
vos débuts dans la série il vous propose
de revenir dans la série julie lescaut à
un million de francs l'épisode pizza
pizza pizza
millions de francs épisode
alors vous embarquez nicole kidman on
est lui lui moi je rencontre jean pierre
guérin julie les stats recall kidman
selon marc nicole kidman c'est le real
en même temps vous prenez votre voiture
vous allez prendre un dernier verre au
costes et là vous lui dites nicole
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
croit je ne suis pas d'oran je suis
américain
et déroutant merde ça c'est pour
commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme ça
quelques mois
jean-paul
vous quittez la soirée un retour j'en ai
marre d'être avec serait en fait sur
marion game
vous allez au cost ouais si vous
rencontrez alain chabat et nicole kidman
qui sont en train de prendre un dernier
verre il fait l'américain à ce cas vous
vous asseyez vous êtes là tous les trois
ou gréco et bien c'est le coup ophélie
winter arrive chez bonjour au filet mais
comme chose dans les cheveux
je peux en parler et l'allemand demande
pourquoi basse et c'est un truc et
qu'ardisson pas dire bonjour normalement
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de linda
hardy tube abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu